[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans l'émission au
point de vue je vous présente les deux
invités qui ont accepté d'y participer
richard bouygues bonjour vous êtes
premier adjoint ps au maire du 12e
arrondissement de paris chargée
notamment de l'économie l'attractivité
des commerces et vous êtes également co
directeur de l'observatoire sport et
sociétés à la fondation jean jaurès face
à vous jean christophe buisson bonjour
vous êtes directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du figaro magazine figaro
magazine qui fait sa une cette semaine
sur l'offensive des vegan et vous avez
publié en octobre dernier chez michel
lafon un livre avec des photographes
napoléon l'esprit des lieux alors voici
les deux thèmes qui ont retenu notre
attention aujourd'hui
tout d'abord les régionales 2021
les ministres ont ils raison de se
présenter et deuxième thème que nous
gardons pour la deuxième partie de 10
mai 1981 que reste-t-il du socialisme
alors on avait miche marlène schiappa
emmanuelle wargon marie-amélie de
montchalin marc fesneau geneviève
darrieussecq brigitte clincker on a
hésité sur le sort de ce chic lysel mais
finalement la ministre a décidé d'y
aller on attend l'officialisation de la
candidature d'eric dupond moretti dans
les hauts de france à la place
enfin à côté de laurent pied tall ships
qui on verra après ça fait neuf membres
du gouvernement régional
et évidemment je ne cite pas ceux qui
sont candidats pour les départementales
sébastien lecornu gérald darmanin
alors écoutez ce qu'en disait marlène
schiappa s'était auto que du figaro tout
à l'heure alors moi je suis pas une
personne qui reste assise confortable
dans son ministère et qui attend qu'on
lui donne en sièges à une élection
gagnée d'avancé
moi j'aime les défis et je crois que à
paris ya énormément de choses à faire
richard brooks est évidemment pas la
première fois que des membres de
gouvernements vont aux urnes pour des
élections locales mais vous dites quoi
ça fait beaucoup
ils sont trop nombreux à y aller d'un
coup je sais pas si c'est le l'angle et
le biais par lequel je répondrai à cette
question mais je me dis plutôt que
devant la catastrophe où le naufrage
annoncé électorale il ya peut-être la
volonté d'essayer d'envoyer quelques
petite notoriété pour essayer d'amortir
le choc
et dans un deuxième temps je me dis
finalement si ces ministres sont battus
et ce qu'ils restent à leur place ou
est-ce qu'il n'y reste pas et est ce que
finalement en filigrane ya pas l'idée du
remaniement en dhr on nous parle et qui
serait finalement annoncé par une
défaite électorale
un peu précoce pour certains parce que
dit on me dit dans tous les cas je me
dis c'est peut-être pas le nombre oui
c'est peut-être pas est ce qu'un
ministre doit être là ou pas cette
question là elle renvoie aussi à ce
qu'on se fait chair engagement politique
oui à l'engagement politique à ce qu'on
se fait aussi de cette représentation
mais moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'il
ya un choix stratégique double
électorale a limité la casse en tablant
sur une petite notoriété de certains
candidats et 2
je me dis aussi pour certains qui sont
en bout de course va quand même se poser
la question de battues et reste battu il
ne reste pas et le remaniement
m'apparaît un peu prégnant alors on va y
venir
c'est une stratégie volontaire pour ici
vous pourrez essayer de limiter la casse
on a vu qu municipal s'était pas ce qui
avait été le plus performant jean
christophe buisson
non mais là on a l'impression qu'il ya
qu il ya effectivement des ministres
pour un petit peu de notoriété mais on
est vraiment en dessous de la main par
rapport à ce que souhaitait emmanuel
macron il ya un an parce que on fait
référence en février mars et plein de
mini ce qu'il voulait pas y aller qui
hésite et secrétaires d'état justement
craignant un craignant une défaite est
donc un remaniement machiavéliquement
pensé par par l'elysée ou par matignon
mais si on revient en arrière il ya un
nom emmanuel macron a dit je veux des
ministres et je veux du lourd
je veux qu'on aille aux régionales qu'on
ne mangeant pas les régionales et
d'ailleurs je veux souvenez vous à
l'époque on parlait de jean michel
blanquer en iran les 900 ont parlé d'
olivier ferrand en rhône alpes auvergne
contre laurent wauquiez donc on en
voyait quand même des mastodontes du
donc il ya depuis toujours la volonté de
l'elysée de ne pas enchanter les
régionales et d'en faire vraiment un
test électoral et l'année dernière
c'était pourtant pas une période très
propice avait déjà eu quelques petites
défaites de la république en marche donc
donc pour moi c'est pas un coup de dire
maintenant finalisée au contraire il ya
toujours voulu sa macro est hélas il
s'est rendu compte que plus personne n'y
allait et donc il dans les ministres ont
assisté tout à l'heure qui vont y en
avait un ou deux qui ya six mois design
en moi j'y vais pas donc il leur force
un peu la main disons maintenant vous y
allez alors qu'il y ait peut-être une
arrière pensée
c'est possible c'est possible pour
certains mais est ce qu'on est sûr que
s'ils perdent ils vont démissionner
parce que c'est une sorte de
jurisprudence qui étaient dictées par
sarkozy souvenez-vous en 2010 et 1,8 qui
sont passés au tapis quand l'un des
ministres et qui sont complètes et
retenu ensuite comme unis françois
hollande a à perpétuer cette ce début de
tradition rien ne dit quesnel macron va
maintenir cette idée même s'il l'a fait
non j'ai pris en 2017 pour les
législatives je crois qu'il avait payé
il avait conservé cette idée là si vous
êtes oui si vous perdez législatives
oui vous ne restez pas gouvernement sauf
que ces législatives un scrutin national
sepa même chose que les régionales donc
bon il ya peut-être du maccabi ce n'est
peut-être pas dans le mac à vis ma vie
dans une stratégie je pense voilà je
pense qu'elle est quand même
elle est quand même très présente les
sondages ne sont quand même pas si
porteur que les ministres se
propulserait de leur propre volonté pour
aller se faire battre parce que en gros
ce qui est prévu aujourd'hui c'est que
j'en ai pas beaucoup qui gagne voire
même qui en a aucun qui gagne sur les
régionales et sont donc ils soldats
c'est l'abnégation jusqu'au bout c'est
aller vraiment se sacrifier
et donc je pense vraiment qu'elle sait
être logique de dire jusqu'au bout on
serre mais en même temps avec cette
question derrière qui est on serre mais
quand on se fait battre est-ce que
finalement on reste dans le gouvernement
qui pourrait être facile n'y a pas de
remaniement celui qui va jusqu'en 2022
ou en tout cas qui amorce la campagne de
2022 ou est ce qu'à un moment donné
c'est plutôt la logique du remaniement
qui est déjà en filigrane qui permet à
ses ministres d'y aller parce que
derrière on veut amorcer notamment pour
emmanuel macron une autre phase
une autre impulsion au tournant à droite
ouais il ya quand même un petit parce
que tu pendant les 10 alors d'un gros
poids lourds je le vois mal perdant
enfin de prendre ce risque là si alors
juste dresse le tableau eric dupond
moretti qui devrait annoncer sa
candidature soit c'est ce soir soit
demain dans les hauts de france en
remplacement de laurent piété rachesky
les sondages donnaient un petit rachesky
sa liste quoi vers 10% tout juste donc
là avec la marge d'erreur pas sûr de
pouvoir se maintenir
et au fond est-ce que c'est pas ça que
tente maquereau en envoyant du fourneau
riti c'est-à-dire obligé xavier bertrand
à devoir négocier
ouais mais je me demande s'il n'y a pas
autre chose qui est que finalement le
score aux régionales c'est un peu le
capital départ des présidentielles je le
dis très vite mais pour ceux qui vont
aller voter pour les candidats en gros
c'est un petit peu du vote qui peut être
considérée comme une base de départ plus
ou moins ajusté un socle parce qu'un
taux de participation qui sera aussi à
étudier mais un socle quand même sur
lequel mois si on gagne 3% 4 % ont
néanmoins c'est important même sur une
élection régionale le fait que un
candidat lrm passerait de 10 à 14
parce que sa notoriété permettrait
d'agresser plus de choses près ce qu'il
remettrait finalement de l'intensité
dans le combat politique parce qu'il
réussirait à porter une vision quelque
chose je pense que c'est quand même
important à ce stade là à ce moment là
c'est quand même un scrutin national sur
des régions qui sont déjà des gros blocs
grande région paie et gagner ce socle
gagner ce match là même gagné 3 4%
je pense que dans la stratégie
électorale d'emmanuel macron c'est pas
la pelle la même chose de partir dans
les hauts de france à 10 ou de partir à
même chose à 9 donc pour un dupond
moretti
vous êtes perdant mais vous êtes perdant
sur le plan ou le ministre qui est sur
place et gars est perdant par contre sur
la stratégie derrière qui est celle de
2022 emmanuel macron s'est accumulé un
socle s'est constitué un socle sur
lequel on pouvoir reconstruire derrière
moi je pense que l'idée de là l'idée des
régionales perdues c'est l'idée quand
même du socle à trouver pour emmanuel
macron jour d'une astucieuse ce n'est
pas la victoire
je pense là l'élu dit elle est un petit
peu chimérique partout si j'ai bien
compris la victoire venue d'eric dupond
moretti c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour
xavier bertrand à votre avis ah bah vu
la violence de sa réaction je pense que
c'est moi
je m'en cogne ça oui c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle parce que parce qu'il va
prendre il à prendre la place il n'est
pas impossible que gérald darmanin soit
plus qu'au départemental et hip hop wild
est aussi intégré la liste encore
quelques jours nous ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il est intègre et là il faut vraiment
pousser ça on sent bien qu'il va
étouffer des semaines xavier bertrand
alors est-ce qu'ils étouffent aussi avec
un esprit encore une femme à québec en
se disant je les trouve pour d'un
persique 2022 ça me fait un candidat en
moins face à moi éventuellement cela est
tout à fait envisageable
cela dit c'est pas totalement idiot de 2
enfin en ce moment c'est pas idiot mais
c'est assez habile je crois que dupont
moretti a quand même un ancrage local il
a une image populaire par ses origines
enfants d'immigrés femme mère femme de
ménage
il est né à maubeuge il a grandi en
horse et c'est pas le parachutage comme
on en a connu il ya trente ans il ya
quand même du sens à envoyer quelqu'un
en dehors du fait en plus qu'il est
ministre et un ministre qui compte donc
c'est vraiment pris de très mauvaises
nouvelles pour xavier bertrand
quoi qu'il en dise et pour karima delli
et la gauche parce que le portrait qu'en
dresse jean christophe buisson
c'est quelqu'un qui parle à un électorat
de gauche non je pense pas que ce soit
pendant que ce soit a priori claouey
mais je pense que ce n'est pas
prioritairement sur cette cet électorat
que se pose aujourd'hui la question
parce que quelque part une grande partie
des voix
un nom mais je pense qu'un vraiment je
pense que dans laquelle la cartographie
électorale j'ai pas l'impression que ce
soit à la hausse soit prioritaire en
revanche on peut dire qu'il ya des
régions ont été choisis il ya
visiblement de la part du salaire ou
même la volonté de faire des hôtes
france un moment important alors que en
ile de france
on mettra pas une même notoriété un même
candidat avec une capacité à remettre du
débat de l'intensité à remettre du
clivage ont fait pas sa religion de
france on a l'impression que en gros on
ne traite pas valérie pécresse
exactement comme on traite xavier
bertrand mais peut-être est ce par
hasard je sais pas assez bas sur ce nom
mais peut-être en l'occurrence il ya
deux régions qui sont inscrits ont été
voilà tu es c'est hot france et provence
alpes côte d'azur parce que il ya forte
présence du rassemblement national
oui alors on a posé la question sur
twitter les ministres ont ils raison de
se présenter aux régionales
la réponse est assez claire de nos amis
internautes non à 83% chardons bleus
nous dit je suppose que ce ministre
essaye d'assurer un job pour après la
présidentielle
être conseiller régional je passais un
job enfin ça fait partie du job de la
politique d'opposition marque un
ministre doit assumer ses fonctions se
présenter n'est pas honnête vis-à-vis
des citoyens pour aller un peu plus loin
de la question de marc eric
dupond-moretti il a quand même des
chantiers très lourd et notamment
d'ailleurs au parlement il a si ces
projets de loi qui sont d'exclusion est
ce qu'on peut comme ça mené la campagne
de front est-ce qu'il doit démissionner
du gouvernement pour faire campagne
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est une question à
laquelle les candidats doivent répondre
quand agnès buzyn a quitté son poste et
qu'elle est arrivée sur la campagne
parisienne il ya eu cette question est
ce que finalement au moment où on
prépare un peu le pays contre ce qui
allait devenir la crise sanitaire qu'on
a connue est ce que finalement c'est le
bon moment de quitter son poste s'était
même pas le poste est lui-même entendait
céder là il ya vraiment un dossier
mêlant des soins importants est ce qu'on
a le droit de démissionner et quelque
part c'était un peu le côté défection en
rase campagne quoi donc qu'il y avait un
sujet mais encore une fois c'est aux
candidats
je pense qu agnès buzyn elle n'a jamais
convaincu sur le fait que
elle avait fait c'est cet engagement
pour quelque chose vraiment de très
noble elle n'a pas convaincu même son
électorat scora score a été un petit peu
le clos du de la ferme et là je pense
que c'est aux candidats d'aller l'assuré
bien sûr il ya des questions de morale
et d'éthique sur l'utilisation des
moyens publics sur l'utilisation des
moyens du gouvernement
est ce que tout ça est toujours très
honnêtes et est-ce que ça ne biaise pas
un peu l'égalité entre les candidats
c'est vrai c'est une question qui se
posera à tous les coups mais qui se
posent aussi entre sortant et nous et ce
petit challenge donc bref c'est pas que
là mais là il ya un sujet effectivement
qui est jusqu'où on porte les dossiers
mais avec une autre question derrière
c'est avec quelle capacité aujourd'hui
les ministres vont s'ils portaient les
dossiers et ce qu'on leur donne vraiment
la main pour aller jusqu'au bout ou pas
mais pour prolonger votre réflexion
allant au delà où elle enfin c'est
important parce qu'ils expliquent aussi
en partie le la désaffection je pense
des gens pour la politique
vous êtes président de région est en
fait comme vous le dit tout à l'heure et
incertain on voit bien que cette
présidence de région est un marchepied
pour l'élection présidentielle c'est la
grosse au vélo vous dites je me fais
lire là mais dans six mois je m'en vais
parce que je fais une campagne
présidentielle il ya de quoi se poser
des questions de la part des électeurs
qui savent qu'une valérie pécresse
éventuellement laurent wauquiez et
éventuellement et xavier bertrand une
fois qu'il aura consolidé son assise
locale va dire maintenant je
voilà je vous aime les gens c'est ce que
la campagne vous avez bertrand moi je
dis c'est vrai il fait du terrain depuis
cinq ans tous les jours c'est pour ça
qu'il est quand même très bien a cédé à
installer puis bah finalement je vais me
présenter à la présidentielle on peut
ressentir ça comme une forme de trahison
et on peut donc avant de voter en se
disant si je vote pour le faire à lire
c'est pour ça pour ne plus le voir dans
6 mois donc à quoi bon tout ça est quand
même pas très bon je trouve l'idée
démocratique de se dire que l'on nous
sert de tremplin à une carrière
nationale
est-ce que avec les fidèles morissette
avait résidé la région s'il gagne à je
ne sais pas mais en tout cas cette
réflexion qui est juste un mois je là je
l'aurais je l'entends je la partage pour
les égards mais elle se traduit
absolument pas dans les sondages ce dont
vous citer les noms sont ceux qui
aujourd'hui je suis caracole en tête
donc ça veut dire que voilà ça veut dire
que la question quasiment morale éthique
elle vient après la question de la
notoriété et la question finalement
d'une région qui se tient au quai à peu
près gérer enfin tournant c'est ptet pas
tous dans les détails mais il ya cette
sensation normalement on devrait avoir
sur les cinq candidats donc on peut voir
diriger une région peut déloger la
france ouais c'est aussi ce mois ça se
joue un peu dans les deux dans les deux
conductrices fierté de l'électeur gens
ils représentent bien ma région mais si
en plus il va en francs à diriger la
france ça rejaillira sur l'argent juste
bas chirac et la corrèze hollande et la
corrèze à la corrèze on a pas mal
bénéficient que se passe-t-il si un
ministre et est battu écouter ce qu'en
disait ce matin barbara pompili la
ministre de la transition écologique en
20min se présente aux élections
régionales il se présente sur un projet
pour les élections régionales
il ne se présente pas sur le bilan de
son ministère vous voyez la différence
c'est à dire que les citoyens en tout
cas moi c'est ce que ce à quoi je crois
les citoyens quand ils vont voter pour
une personnalité pour les régionales ils
vont voter pour quelqu'un qui pourra
faire quelque chose pour eux pour les
régionales donc sur un projet alors vous
êtes d'accord
les sharks avec barbara pompili qui
scinde les choses voilà j'y vais en tant
que ministre en campagne mais comme
c'est pour les régionales c'est pas en
tant que ministre que je serai
sanctionné non mais sur le papier ce
qu'elle dit est excellent dans la
réalité c'est exactement l'inversé c'est
ça le problème c'est qu'en réalité tous
les candidats qui vont y aller avec
l'étiquette lrm ils seront porteurs du
message présidentiel et du bilan
du quinquennat et à quelques mois de la
fin du quinquennat
on peut pas dire que on est à la
première année la deuxième année on est
au bout et ce sera déjà une heure du
bilan par contre il ya une véritable
envie du gouvernement et emmanuel macron
d'échapper à ce vote sanction parce que
comme en gros les résultats s'annoncent
catastrophiques pour elle et re même
c'est à dire en gros
aucune région gagnée ça veut dire que
derrière si on annonce trop ça qui est
en gros déjà un peu de goût un peu le
goût de la défaite
pour commencer une campagne
présidentielle ce n'est pas très bon
donc à l'envi surtout d'éviter que les
régionales soient abordées comme un
bilan est comme une sanction du bilan du
quinquennat et ce qu'est ce qu'ils
essaient de nous dire en gros
barbara pompili soyez sympa voilà les
éléments de langage surtout si on perd
on ne perd pas parce que le gouvernement
a échoué mais parce que notre projet
régional n'aura pas été bon projet
régional que tous les électeurs connaît
les manteaux en train de se dire que si
jamais elle y va et que lui et puis ce
reste ministre c'est possible elle teste
ça mais je pense qu'elle résultat les 20
et 27 juin pour moment du résultat des
élections régionales et départementales
n'oublions pas le deuxième thème nos
ramène 40 ans en arrière 10 mai 1981 que
reste-t-il du socialisme vous souvenez
de ce que vous faisiez le 10 mai 1981 au
soir oui vous faisiez quoi j'étais une
place de la bastille n'ont même pas oui
et c'est bien parce qu'en fait il ya
plusieurs moments dans le 10 mai j'avais
deux parents des parents qui tenait des
bureaux de vote
voilà est donc d'abord il ya eu le
moment où mon père après une pause
juste avant le dépouillement final pour
aller regarder ce qui se passait à la
télé il a vu le résultat
il est parti tout de suite il a pas des
bouillet il ya eu il ya quelques minutes
de retard et ma mère était dans le
bureau de vote au site
donc voilà donc il ya eu un grand fière
de mon père j'étais mois après je suis
rentré à la maison pour les attendent
sagement et après on est partis classe
de la veste sous la douche voilà qui on
annoncera d'autres mais voilà j'en reste
aux buissons de ne pas vous n'étiez pas
place de la bastille sous leur acheter
donc parce que je n'habitais pas paris
ah ben voilà provincial de l'asbl
l'hiver n'ont même pas les faits tout
petit village de la loire mais ma mère
travailler pour un député qui s'appelait
pascal clément donc n'est pas très
heureuse du résultat et je crois que moi
j'étais à le promotionnaire j'avais 12
ans que j'étais à la maison avec mon
père qui lui devait pas totalement
hostile à l'idée que mitterrand
succèdent jusqu'à s'était pas vraiment
sa tasse de thé il a un petit côté anar
ça pas lui déplaire d'une façon j'étais
en pension donc je pense que à 8h15 gta
v était rentré pour partir dans le même
temps prendre le bus à 6 heures est le
cas ce collège
alors notre question que reste-t-il du
socialisme on a posé la question
pareille sur twitter le socialisme
existe-t-il encore la réponse
là aussi est très net vous allez la voir
s'afficher non à 80% richard brooks à
bout désole ça vous étonne comment vous
réagissez
maintenant je suis pas à me désole ni
étonné enfin d'abord on est sûr partie
des personnes qui répondent plutôt
j'allais dire on s'est tu quand cette
impression donc faut pas donner plus
de commentaires sur ça je suis pas
tellement surpris que ça interroge sur
aujourd'hui l'existence du socialisme
après l'espoir qu'elles étaient portés
en 1980 et ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près je pense une question
scène
après je sais pas si la manière dont
léon blum expliquer la naissance du
socialisme 6 dont celle de jaurès
expliquer ce que serait la bataille
finale du socialisme c'est à dire les
notions à la fois d'égalité les notions
de paix dans le monde les notions de
justice sociale si ces notions là nous
ont complètement échappé aujourd'hui
en revanche leur mise en oeuvre leur
traduction politique interroge et en
fait il ya presque un paradoxe on n'a
presque jamais eu autant besoin de
socialisme si on fait le constat de la
société comme elle va et on a eu jamais
eu autant d'interrogations sur la
capacité des socialistes a dirigé à
prendre le pouvoir donc c'est cette
espèce de fossé entre les deux qui
mérite interrogations enfin dans les
legs mais je me rappelle quand même que
le 10 mai 81 on nous annonçait de
manière à la fois amusé mais l'arrivée
des chars russes ne se sont jamais
arrivés et quant au mur de l'argent et
aux 200 familles j'ai des relations
clérisse n'ont jamais été aussi riche
qu'aujourd'hui donc en gros ce qui était
les catastrophes annoncées pour les uns
et les autres
les chars ne sont pas là les riches sont
toujours riches voire encore plus qu'il
ne l'était en 1981 c'est à la fois un
aveu d'échec et en même temps un aveu
comme pour ceux qui ont vu arriver
l'ogre rouge qu'ils n'étaient pas là
quoi en même temps on est passé de
l'ombre à la lumière
ce jour là comme dirait jack lang qu'est
ce qui reste du socialisme sont
présentes
je plaisante à peine en disant ça
d'ailleurs c'est lui qui est omniprésent
et dans ces festivités pour une raison
très simple c'est que je vais employer
le mot la fête chaque langue c'est
incarne la fête l'esprit de fête et il a
survécu à ça parce que tout le reste qui
était sérieux et qui c'est à mon sens
très mal passé on essaie de le cacher
pour une raison très simple je pense que
le socialisme en france a souffert
d'un défaut majeur c'est de ne pas faire
son bad godesberg je sais que c'est un
cliché de dire ça c'était de faire son
congrès on absents on abandonne le
marxisme comme référence de la pensée
socialiste qu'ont fait les allemands ont
fait beau et les français ont gardé
cette idée là alors qu'il est un parti
communiste très fort ils sont jamais
débarrassé de cette de cette prégnance
de l'idée marxiste qui était je pense à
ces nobles dans sa critique le marxiste
du sens aux diverses dans la critique du
système capitaliste en train de naître
minet plus de 106 avait d'autant moins
de sens que les régimes qui se réclamer
de lui étaient des régimes totalitaires
qui faisait d extermination de masse et
que si c'est arrivé effectivement à
l'égalité entre les citoyens en en
mettant la moitié en prison ou dans des
camps ça ne semble pas une très bonne
une très bonne idée et pourtant on
continue à assumer jusqu'à une date
récente le marxisme qui continuent
d'ailleurs à imprégner je pense
la société ne faisait d'ailleurs étant
parti socialiste il faut pas se leurrer
quand on voit les prélèvements
obligatoires qui sont les autres c'est
pas vraiment des prairies en gloire
d'une société ultralibérale donc le
socialiste existe encore dans les mots
dans les faits dans l'esprit dans
l'idéal dans l'utopie dans l'idée que le
travail est moins important que
que le loisir que plein d'activités que
le travail comme une aliénation ça ça
reste du substrat un marxiste qui reste
imprégnée dans la pensée socialiste
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui socialistes
n'ont de sens que lorsqu'ils sont avec
les économique parce qu'il porte un
discours écologiste je crois que c'est
d'ailleurs un petit peu le sens de de ce
que veut faire olivier faure parce qu'en
tant que tel il a perdu à mon sens
beaucoup de de crédibilité et puis le
parti socialiste ça va devenir dans les
années 80 aussi le règne de l'argent ou
les dix on a de la bourse s'est jamais
aussi bien portée dans les années 80 les
gens ne sont jamais devenus aussi riche
que sous le socialisme du mitterrand
avec des affaires corruption de
corruption qu'on connaît avec un jeu
trouble avec le front national pour se
maintenir au pouvoir c'est le socialiste
est devenu abandonné du cynisme
politique l'incarnation même du cynisme
en politique donc mais ce qui n'empêche
pas que beaucoup de socialistes sont
très sincère et en raison de croire aux
valeurs qui sont les leurs mais comme
vous l'avez dit la mise en application
n'a pas été tout à fait à la hauteur de
l'espoir qui a pu être remis avant je
vous livre trois réflexions de nos amis
qui nous écoutent anatole dit oui le
socialisme existe encore mais je ne
pense pas qu'il soit incarné par le ps
qui a bafoué ce mot avec la loi travail
sa politique ultra libérale
micheline nous dit le parti socialiste
ne sera plus en haut de la fiche c'est
une page qui se tourne et on n'y peut
rien et baudoin le socialisme est à
réinventer mais ses partisans proclamé
manque d'imagination quand un atoll dit
le socialiste existe encore mais il n'y
pas incarnée par parti socialiste c'est
d'accord avec ça c'est vrai comment il
est historiquement le socialisme n'est
pas incarné que par le parti socialiste
les archives socialistes ne sont pas les
archives du parti socialiste il se
trouve que dans l'histoire de la gauche
le parti socialiste a eu un rôle
prééminent par rapport à d'autres
formations politiques mais
lalaye voilà le parti socialiste mais
qui alterne le socialisme aujourd'hui
pour vous moi je sais je sais pas parce
que j'ai l'impression que le socialisme
aujourd'hui et en grande interrogation
est dire que quelqu'un aujourd'hui à la
réponse à la question je ne sais pas si
moi j'ai pas trop d'accord sur le propos
sur olivier faure je pense que la voie
est compliqué c'est à dire comment
réinvente aujourd'hui le socialisme mais
quand le parti socialiste réfléchi sur
toute la conception qu'il a autour du
travail aujourd'hui travailler enfin une
réfléchir sur l'ubs et risation du
travail réfléchir sur tous les salariés
des plateformes réfléchir sur
aujourd'hui le travail notamment de ceux
qui sont obligés de cumuler plusieurs
emplois ceux qui sont obligés d'avoir du
temps partiel qui n'est pas choisie mais
qui est imposé je pense que toutes ces
réflexions là sont des réflexions qui
sont dans la tradition et dans
l'histoire des socialistes qui est de
dire que le travail ne doit pas aliéner
le travail doit être protégé doit être
un moment où les gens se réalise non pas
où les gens sont en situation d'être
exploités ou dominer tout ça continue
simplement aujourd'hui disons le notre
société elle est moins réceptive à ce
type de combat et à ce type de propos
qu'elle ne l'est à d'autres enjeux qui
sont notamment les enjeux climatiques
pour lesquels il y a une caisse de
résonance qui est beaucoup plus
importante et avec un paradoxe qui est
qu'on oppose les deux quant à beaucoup
d'endroits sur des situations la cause
dit climatique est la cause sociale
peuvent se rejoindre et peuvent
s'entendre comme étant l'une et l'autre
complémentaires et tout l'enjeu des
socialistes aujourd'hui c'est de montrer
que le combat pour une société plus
juste pour une société avec plus
d'égalité plus de fraternité continue et
qu'elle ait percuté par un enjeu mais
qui n'est pas de faire la terre plus
belle mais qui est de se dire que pour
réussir l'égalité entre les hommes il ya
aujourd'hui un défi qui s'est imposée
qui est celui du défi climatique et
qu'on ne pourra pas aller vers une
société plus juste centre mais ça c'est
dur à expliquer aux gens c'est dur de le
faire en cinq ans de 140 caractères
c'est dur de le faire sur un post
facebook et c'est dur de le faire
aujourd'hui donc là où j'entends c'est
il ya peut-être un manque d'innovation
oui parce qu'il ya un logiciel a
réinventé il ya quelque chose qui s'est
aussi usé avec le pouvoir
ce que dit
la personne je l'entends les socialistes
ne sont plus les seuls à porter les
diocèses oui d'ailleurs c'est tout le
propos je crois du parti socialiste de
dire qu'il a été une place qui était
dominante elle ne l'est plus aujourd'hui
faut composer les régionales dont on
parlait tout à l'heure en sont
l'illustration dans le nord de la france
on on le voit mais je crois que ça va
être aussi vrai dans d'autres régions
plus au sud et dont il ya cette idée que
effectivement le jeu politique n'est
n'est plus exactement le même
mais cette idée du socialisme encore une
fois c'est deux choses différentes
l'avenir du parti socialiste est
l'avenir du socialisme peut-être que ce
n'est pas exactement la même vague lors
des mois il me semble qu'en 80 la notion
d'incarnation et qu'en mai quand un
crucial quoi qu'on en dise c'est à dire
qu' il fallait que ce soit mitterrand
pour boucler ce week-end en 80 il
fallait quelqu'un qui soit assez habile
pour étouffer le parti communiste sur
sur sa gauche et puis ensuite manipuler
un peu ce qui se passait à droite pour
au pot pour rester au pouvoir donc c'est
quand même ça la politique et je pense
qu'en 80 le discours notamment sur le
travail était très clair chez les
socialistes
il ya vraiment rupture avec le discours
libéral centriste jusqu'à 10 kg le
problème c'est que le discours que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure il est partagé
par plein de gens y compris à droite
c'est pas vrai bah si c'est pas alors
quand il ya de la personnalité en
contiennent trois qui sont celles là
pour faire une égalité une meilleure
égalité et bunge de justice sociale
simplement c'est pas le tout à fait les
moyens que les socialistes mais il ya
plein de libéraux et les conservateurs
qui suffisent bah si mais alors pourquoi
en termes de volonté si je vais alors
pourquoi quand un projet de loi il est
une drogue sociale alors pourquoi quand
une proposition de loi pour être exact
porté par les socialistes sur l'ubs et
risation sur les crêtes à bien parce que
c'est ça vient du socialisme et ça
jouait pas d'accord mais ouais d'accord
là dessus donc pourquoi la politique en
france le sujet pendant les trois grâces
ont de bonnes idées de gauche et de
gauche sans doute pas de donner des
droits mais ça n'empêche pas ils n'en
pensent pas moins
alors s'il sait va dans les deux sens
mais on est d'accord moi je
j'invite vraiment à ce que les sénateurs
de droite notamment créé un intergroupe
s'ils le veulent propose de leur ca mais
qui dressent leur proposition de loi
alors pourquoi il ne le faut on va sur
ces sujets s'ils sont importants et
qu'on peut s'y retrouver
s'ils ne veulent pas voter le sud la
proposition de loi de la gauche peut
être que la gauche aura l'intelligence
de soutenir celles de la droite si elle
est à peu près la même oui on verra non
franchement revenons sur notre sujet
1980 il jure ne sais pas si vous avez
écouté jacques attali hier soir ce qu'il
a dit c'était dans l'émission c'est ce
soir sur france 5 il a comparé françois
mitterrand et marine le pen
je vous laisse écouter et on entend vos
réactions après il y a des points
communs disons un arian 203 troisième
candidature comme lui le fait qu'on a
toujours pensé qu'il serait jamais élu
on ne peut pas un plafond de verre la
gauche pourra pas passer le fait qu'il
avait un programme impossible qui ferait
venir les chars russes soviétique dans
paris le fait qu'il avait des idées des
alliés qu'elle étouffe la production a
battu le fait le fait que dans le coin
d'averses
comme pour françois mitterrand j'ai vu
des gens qui ont tout fait pour françois
mitterrand soit élu évidemment sur
chaque point pris individuellement on
voit le parallèle mais comment vous
réagissez à ce parallèle marine le pen
va françois mitterrand égale marine le
pen
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire je sais
pas si il met un égal entre les deux il
met un point commun ils mettent tous ces
points communs en dix ans et à la fin il
dit elle peut gagner
ah oui mais ces séances est encore une
c'est encore une autre point pour moi
une autre démonstration et ce qu'elle
peut gagner aujourd'hui notre façon une
élection n'est jamais joué d'avancé
franchement dire aujourd'hui elle
elle peut que perdre je pense que c'est
se tromper complètement sur la spa
parallèle qu'il était parallèle de ces
parallèles de jacques attali les deux
sociétés sont quand même complètement
différente on n'est pas du tout avec le
même jeu politique
on n'a pas du tout une bataille qui est
celle qui était celle de 80 aujourd'hui
bien sûr franchement je suis franchement
le côté ça fait trois fois qu'il se
présente enfin je pense que c'est pas
fatale c'est pas parce qu'on se présente
pour une troisième fois qu'on est
forcément élue la troisième fois face à
ça a marché pour milers à manger pour
chirac ouais mais si je reste en vie
sans moi je m'intéresse pas d'être homo
mais je trouve la manière dont tu parles
d'une certaine marine le pen c'est une
ultra banalisation c'est à dire il ya
plus de discours en disant à la base il
ya quand même un danger c'est un ya un
côté oui et puis la conclusion c'est
effectivement elle peut gagner comité a
regagné puisque elle aligne les mêmes
les mêmes qualités et les mêmes défauts
moi je trouve qu'il ya dans ce disque
aux espèces de tranquillité de sérénité
à faire effectivement et je dis pas
c'est bien mal comme si leur assemblée
nationale était vraiment un parti comme
un autre venant d'attali je suis assez
surpris j'aurais du mal après entendre
des gens de son camp qui vont expliquer
que la droite extrême droite sans
entente vu la manière dont lui même
parle de façon totalement de 30 vous
pensent qu'il est pris par son côté
brillant intellectuel il fait une
démonstration brillante mais l'epa
politique en l'occurrence mais ce n'est
pas neutre
c'est celui qui accompagnait françois
mitterrand 80 oui mais oui on a tous vu
on a tous la possibilité d'avoir après
des comparaisons et des discours qu'on
évolue depuis 80 ça fait 40 ans le
national est vraiment un parti comme un
autre qu'on traite comme la roue je n'ai
pu obtenir et parmi 15 quand il fait ça
c'est csc-enseignement oui c'est mon
avis n'est que là dessus je ne le suis
pas d'accord d'accord
et bien c'est sur ce point que nous
terminons poursuite à vue sur ce
l'émission merci à tous les deux dit
avoir participer merci de nous avoir
suivis et à lundi pour une prochaine
émission de point de vue
[Musique]